n'hésites partielle de type transitoire
par exemple pour sa soeur
vous reconnaissez paul c'est paul se
connaît pas aux
mamies se rappelle d'un certain gg peut
trouver j'ai pour trouver mamie
à les opérations mamie
gg c'est tout droit par si ce pays jugés
c'est marrant
toi tu vas à la cuisine c'est un fait de
gonzesses quoi
après 45 ans tu te bouges ma gueule
enfarinée
mille gama s'est toujours des hommes et
dames c'était un enfant qui vous avec un
vent de 10 12 ans une date de péremption
temps là
on va les chercher on les rapatrie
d'urgence je m'occupe des billets des
bagnoles et moi du pinard les plus
petits
[Musique]
la partie
elle est folle amoureuse de toi rohr tu
savais qu'elle se souvenait que toi on
croit que c'est facile quand on bloque
la paix sont comme ça vieux fou tu vu on
doit traverser la france pour toi mais
c'est quoi ce produit
le cas